[موسيقى]
طيب سيد ابراهيم في بحثنا عنكم هو المعتاد
في البعد الاخر
قيل كثيرا عنك او عرف عنك بانك رمز
للاستقلاليه والحياد فيما كتب لكن الصوره
الان بشانك تبدو مختلفه يصر معارضوا هذا
البرلمان على تقديمك على خلاف صوره الرجل
النزيه التي اظهرتها عندما قد منظمات
وطنيه كيف تنظرون لهذا
اولا وبذات لازلت على تلك الصوره
تقدمت بوصف مستقل ونزلت يعني
مصر على الاستقلاليه
يعني بالنسبه لي كموقف سواء عندما كنت في
عماد المحامين او الى الان يعني
مبادره 25 جويليه لان
رئيس الدوله انذاك والى الان يعني
اعلن محاربه الفساد
وبلادنا استشر فيها الفساد واصبح ينخر كل
المفاصل الدوله ولذلك لا يمكن انقاذ هذه
البلاد الا بالقضاء على الفساد وما دام
يعني رئيس الدوله ينتحي هذا النحو
ويعلن يعني الحرب الى هواده على الفساد
فانا اساندهم مساندهم مطلقه وهذا لا يمس
من استقلاليه بل بالعكس هو يعني
برهان على اني مستقل في الافكار وعندما
يتراجع عن هذا الدور لكل حادث حديث
ما الذي حدث لتغير رايك بشان ذلك الدستور
اولا لم اكن اعوذ بالمستاسيسي بل كنت عضو
يعني
اللجنه لجنه تحقيق هدف الثوره والاصلاح
السياسي والانتقال الديمقراطي اللجنه التي
وقع بعثها قبل المجلس التاسيسي وهي التي
بعملها انتج المجلس المجلس التاسيسي علي
اتحال فعلا في السابق كنت يعني
ربما
مناسب لفكره النظام البرلماني الحقيقي لا
البرلمانات المزيفه يعني برلمان معدل
ورئاسي معدل ولكن الوضع بعد التجربه
والوضع الذي مررنا به في بلادنا طيله
العشر سنوات الاخيره حتى ما وانه لابد من
ان يكون هناك مسؤول في الوظيفه التنفيذيه
ويعني به رئيس الدوله والحكومه
على نجاح السياسه سياسه
سياسه الوظيفه التنفيذيه او كذلك مسؤولين
على الفشل وبالتالي فان الدستور الذي وقع
قراره يوم 25 جويليه 22 فعلا اصبحت يعني
الوظيفه التنفيذيه مسؤوله عن كل نتائج
الحكم سواء كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه
وبالتالي
فان موقفي لم يتغير
وبتبيعه الحال يعني الاجتهادات السياسيه
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ضرره النزج الشعبي
ودرجه التطور يعني الفكري للشعب في الهاتف
المرحله يحتاج الشعب التونسي الى توضيح
المواقف والى الاهتمام باولويات هامه من
جملتها يعني استقرار المسار السياسي
وتنميه المسار الاقتصادي واصلاح الوضع
الاجتماعي ثم اكثر من ذلك اننا يعني نحن
امام حرب حقيقيه
قصد القضاء على الفساد الذي استشر في كامل
مفاصل البلاد وباذن الله سننتصر في
النهايه ونحقق ما يتمناه الشعب التونسي